have you ever wanted to just travel the
world
free of any financial worry learn all
you can from the different tastes of the
planet
all on your own while bettering yourself
have you also
perhaps wanted to meet beautiful women
left and right on these travels
win them over with your naturally weird
perverted and
somehow inspiring self well
that is exactly what the main character
of golden boy kintaro
is doing kintoro is a 25 year old
college dropout
the fine print being of course that he
mastered the university's entire
curriculum before leaving
and now in his pursuit of learning more
of anything and
everything on his trusty bike crescent
moon guiding him he travels japan
as a freeder taking odd jobs wherever he
can find them
and in this short six episode comedy
anime he meets a new woman
each episode in this journey usually
doing some kind
of work or odd job for them and while he
always makes a terrible first impression
because of some humorous antic he does
like licking their toilet seat or
absolutely failing at the job they've
given him
after each 28-minute episode he somehow
finds a way to win their heart
always but not on purpose either as
despite kintaro's lust for women
what always takes priority for him is
knowledge
and just as the women find out who the
real kintaro is a smart and
rather charming young free soul he
disappears onto his next job just as
suddenly
as he appeared
originally serialized in 1992 and
adapted into an anime ova in 1995
golden boy is one of the oldest comedy
anime out there and is a trailblazer for
future edgy comedy anime to come
it has such a distinct charm in the
episodic format one of the best examples
of short individual episodes perfectly
matching the story's fleeting plot as
quintoro moved from place to place
join me as i explore the short and sweet
story of golden boy
and why it absolutely stands the test of
time as the grandfather of modern comedy
anime
right after you like and subscribe of
course i see the 90
of you you ain't slick please subscribe
let's go
[Music]
i'll give the rundown of the first
episode to describe the show because the
episodes do follow roughly the same idea
so this will give you a pretty accurate
representation of what golden boys is
all about
first off truckkun comes out of nowhere
and
oh wait no that's not the right kind of
story but he does get ran over by a car
but it's a beautiful broad in her
ferrari and she gives him a million yen
which is
[Music]
nine grand which would have been even
more back then in 1992
so she's swimming in it and so is
quintaro now actually
quintoto then proceeds to get crescent
moon fixed up because
i mean he got hit by a car and then some
yakuza guys come to get their money from
the bike fixer old man
and kintaro just dips
and proceeds to go to the odd job he
found in an office full of
only women and the boss you guessed it
the blonde broad from before and he's
loving every second of it
cleaning the boss's toilet done he's
even so kind as to test how clean it is
by rubbing his face
across the seat and drinking the bidet
water to make sure it's fresh
if you couldn't tell that was sarcasm it
was
he actually just realizes this is where
she uses the bathroom and uh
does his hair have mercy i'm she lets it
slide once she catches him and quintoro
continues to learn how the workplace
goes and associates with all the other
workers
because he's a pretty nice guy taking
notes in his trusty notebook as always
but then as he's closing up shop he
accidentally unplugs the computer that
had the boss's code that she's been
working on for three months
and he's fired right after he gets one
last taste though
and as the office tries to remake the
code in the week before their deadline
which they clearly can't do but i mean
at least they look good doing it
kantoro comes and drops off a disc
containing the code
but better and then as they chase him
down to give him
thanks or ask how he did it they find
the old man who fixed his bike who
reveals that kintoro actually gave him
the million yen from earlier to pay his
debt to the yakuza
and then everyone realizes that kintaro
is literally the goat
like this dude is perfect and then our
lovely lady goes into the sunset to
search for him
not knowing that he's disappeared onto
his next pursuit of knowledge
first as i'm sure you've noticed from
the scenes i've included the facial
expressions in golden boy
are hilarious this is something that old
anime in my opinion
generally do much better than new shows
or more consistently
is making these almost caricature-like
faces that bring out so much more humor
to the scenes and it makes it all the
better that kantaro never hides what
he's thinking or how he's feeling
you see it all whether he says it
outright or through his facial
expressions
and it's in these almost unbelievable
parts of the show and its willingness to
go there that i also love
from biking on actual power lines to him
making out with a dude who thinks he's
someone else and he never realizes it
to twisting his head an entire 180
degrees
today's lesson the human head cannot
turn
360 degrees
the show managed to integrate many out
of the ordinary aspects into this
grounded and individual journey that
kintaro is on
which actually kind of fits when you
realize the origins of kintaro himself
the name kintaro is translated as golden
boy in japanese
and refers to a famous japanese folklore
story
back in the day kintaro grew up in
nature with his mother as a strong and
energetic young boy who befriended all
the animals around him
he was stronger than all of them and was
just as our friendly perverted kindero
is
a free soul one with the world
and then he got recruited to become some
big vassal swordsman sakata kintoki
even his last name oy i believe is a
play on the fable of kintoro defeating
an
ogre that lived on mount oi so from the
very start
our kintaro and golden boy is rooted in
folk tales and myths
just as he disappears as if he were
never there never existed in each
episode
it's almost as if each of the six parts
are not just
episodes but single folk stories of the
traveling quintoro
a myth that has parts that you would
never believe but a character who's so
real and understandable that you can't
help up believe
and honestly i can say how inspiring it
is and blah blah but
golden boy is really just a hilarious
anime and i would be fine just leaving
it at that
with kintaro revealing hidden talents of
his that he's picked up from
who knows where on his journey to having
obscure antics with all these different
women
each episode is the same format but
they're also dynamically different
a dominating but kind boss a young
daughter of a yakuza boss with a daddy
complex
an innocent woman being enticed by a
scammer they're all so distinct from
each other
he always finds himself in the worst
positions most of the time because he's
just so hilariously stupid but
also so wide beyond his ears at the same
time
imagine this you've been caught
red-handed staged to seem like you cut
up the clothes of a yakuza boss's
daughter
his whole gang is on you so what do you
do beg for mercy
kintaro doesn't he makes out with her in
front of them and claims he's in love
and proceeds to get his ass he never
shies
away from an opportunity
[Music]
many anime especially comedy follow this
episodic format that golden boy has
where each episode starts
and ends its own story sometimes in the
case of say
the way of the house husband or the
disastrous life of psyche k
its multiple shorts fit within the
actual 20 minute episode so
it's even more but as i've been saying i
think golden boy truly set the standard
of a good episodic anime
kintaro experiences a new job and sees a
new woman
in each fleeting episode and moves on to
his next step
so that despite being episodic it always
feels like it's going somewhere
that he's in pursuit of a new
opportunity
which is a big problem these kind of
anime have feeling
almost pointless sometimes but finding
purpose in the pointless things
is exactly what kintaro loves to do
if you have three hours on your hand at
any point in the next few days
give golden boy a watch its short length
is perfect for anyone looking for a
quick anime
and if you've already seen it did you
like it i feel like it's very hard to
hate the show because it is so
unashamedly funny and perverted and
exactly what the synopsis says
nothing more and nothing less he keeps
moving forward
always on the lookout for new knowledge
and adventure
and who knows perhaps someday he may
even
save the world that's the beauty of
golden boy
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses
you